People though. They really are.
It's just fucking hard business,
especially when you didn't
see it coming to one.
Hello Renee. Hello. Thanks for
doing this. I really appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.
I listened to you on Sam Harris'
podcast and I was utterly stunned.
I had to listen to it twice cause I just
couldn't believe it. Let's get into,
let's get into this from the beginning.
How did this start out?
How did you start researching these,
a online Russian trolls
and bots and all this jazz?
Yeah, so a couple of years
back in around 2015, um, I,
I had had my,
my first baby in 2013 and I was getting
on these preschool lists and what I
decided to do was I started looking at,
um,
anti vaccine activity in California
because I had a kid and I wanted to, uh,
you know,
put them on preschool list.
I was going to fit with
the parents basically, um,
as someone who vaccinates and I started
looking at the way that small groups,
we're able to kind of disproportionately
amplify messages on social channels.
And some of this was through
very legitimate activity.
And then some of it was through really
kind of coordinated deliberate attempts
to Kinda game, um, ways that
algorithms were amplifying content,
amplifying particular types of narratives.
And I thought it was interesting and
I started writing about it and I, um,
I wound up writing about ways in
which, um, hashtag gaming, um,
ways in which people were kind of using
automation to just be in a Hashtag all
the time.
So it was kind of a way to really gain
control of share voice and what that
meant when very small groups of people
could achieve this kind of phenomenal
amplification and what the pros and cons
of that were. And then this was, um,
2015. So the way that,
that this sort of, um,
awareness of social media challenges came,
came about was actually
when I was working on this.
Other people were looking at it from the
same, I'm looking at the same tactics,
but how they were being used by Isis,
by the terrorist organization.
And they're also,
you had this very small group of
people that manage to use bots and
amplification to really kind of own
a narrative, really pushed this,
this brand is this digital caliphate to
kind of build it on all social platforms
almost simultaneously.
And the ways in which information was
hopping from one platform to another, um,
through kind of deliberate coordination
and then also just ways in which
information flows, kind
of contagion style. Um,
and I wound up working on thinking about
how the government was going to respond
to the challenge of
terrorist organizations using
American social platforms to
spread propaganda.
Uh,
so what we came to realize was that
there was just this information ecosystem
and it had evolved in a certain way over
a period of about eight years or so.
And the kind of unintended consequences
of that and the way that Russia kind of
came into the conversation
was around October,
2015 when we were thinking about what,
what to do about Isis,
what to do about terrorism
and terrorist, uh, you know,
kind of proliferation on social platforms.
This was right around when
Chen had written the article,
the Agency for the New York Times.
And that was one of the first big expos
A's of the Internet research agency.
The first time in American journalist
had gone over there and actually met the
trolls,
been in Saint Petersburg,
and began to write about
what was happening over
there and the ways that they
had pages that we're targeting
certain facets of American culture.
So while we were in DC talking about
what to do about terrorists using these
platforms to spread propaganda,
there were beginning to be rumblings
that Russian intelligence and you know,
Russian entities, we're doing the same
thing. And so the question became,
can we think about ways in which the
Internet is vulnerable to this type of
manipulation by anyone? And then, um,
and then come up with ways to stop it.
So that was how the Russia
investigation began,
was actually around 2015 and a handful
of people started looking for evidence of
Russian bots and trolls
on social platforms.
So 2015 if we think about social
media and the birth of social media,
essentially, it had only been alive
for, I mean, what was Twitter,
2007 I believe. I think so, yeah.
Something like that. So eight years,
like eight years of social media and
then all of a sudden they figured out how
to game the system and then they figured
out how to use this to make people
argue against each other.
Yeah, I think so. There was this,
uh, if you go back to like, um,
you remember like Geo cities and they,
yeah. Okay. AOL Use that course. Um,
so we're probably about the same age.
Um, so there have always been, you know,
kind of the thing thing that was great
about the Internet, like Internet 1.0,
we can call it,
right.
It was this idea that everybody was
given a platform and you could use your
platform, you could put up your blog,
you could say whatever you wanted. Um,
you didn't necessarily get attention,
but you could say whatever you wanted.
And so there is this
kind of consolidation as,
as social platforms kind of came
into existence, content creators.
We're really excited about the fact
that now they not only had this, um,
this access to write their own stuff,
but they also had access to this audience
because as the network effects got
more and more pronounced, more and more
people came to be on social platforms.
And an originally it wasn't even Facebook,
if you remember, it was like, you know,
there's like Friendster and myspace
and social networks kind of evolved.
When I was in college, Facebook was
still limited to like, you know,
a handful of like Ivy League schools.
And so I wasn't even eligible. And, um,
as you watch this consolidation happen,
you,
you start to have this information
ecosystem really dominated by a handful of
companies that grow very large because
they're providing a service that people
really want.
Um,
but there's a kind of mass consolidation
of audiences onto this handful of
platforms.
So this becomes really interesting for
regular people who just want to find
their friends, reach people, spread
their message, growing audience.
It also becomes really interesting for
propagandists and trolls and in this case
terrorist organizations and
state intelligence services.
Cause instead of reaching
the entire Internet,
they really just kind of have to
concentrate their efforts on a handful of
platforms.
So that consolidation is one of the
things that kind of kicks off some of the,
um, one of one of the reasons
that we have these problems today,
right? So the, the fact that
there's only a Facebook,
a Twitter and Instagram and a couple
other minor platforms other than Youtube,
I mean anything that you can
tell it's an actual person,
like youtube is a problem, right? Because
you could see it's an actual person.
If you have, you're narrating
something, you, you know,
if you're in front of the camera and
explaining things and people were going to
know that you're an actual human being.
Whereas there's so many of these
accounts that I'll go to, like I'll,
I'll watch people get involved in these
little online beefs with each other and
then I'll go to some of these accounts.
I'm like,
this doesn't seem like a real person.
And I'll go and it's like Hashtag Maga,
there's a American Eagle in
front of a flag. And then you,
you read their stuff and
you're like, wow, this is,
this is probably a Russian troll account.
And it's strange,
like you feel like you're not
supposed to be seeing this.
Like you've seen the wiring under the
board or something and then you'll go
through the timeline and all they're
doing is engaging people and arguing,
you know, for Trump and against, you know,
whatever the fuck they're angry
about, whatever, whatever it is,
it's being discussed and they're,
they're basically just like some
weird little argument mechanism.
Yeah. So in 2016, um,
there was a lot of that during
the presidential campaign,
right. And there were,
um, there was so much that
was written, you know,
we can go back to the free speech thing
we were kind of chatting about before.
There's so much that was written about,
um,
harassment and trolling and negativity
and these kind of hoards of accounts that
would brigade people and harass them.
Of course,
a lot of that is just real Americans,
right?
There are plenty of people who are just
assholes on the Internet. Sure. Um,
but there were actually a fair
number of these as we began to do the
investigation into the
Russian operation in,
and it started on Twitter and
about, um, 2014, actually, so 2013,
2014, the Internet research agency
is targeting Russian people.
So they're tweeting in Russian,
at Russian and Ukrainian are folks,
people in their sphere of influence.
So they're already on there.
They're already trying this out.
And what they're doing is they're
creating these, uh, these, these accounts.
It's kind of wrong to call them
bots because they are real people.
They're just not what they appear to be.
So I think the unfortunate term
for it has become like Cyborg,
like semi automated. You know,
sometimes it's automated,
sometimes it's a real person,
but a sock puppet is the other
way that we can refer to it.
A person pretending to be somebody else.
So you have these sock puppets and
they're out there and they're tweeting.
And in 2014 about the Russian
annexation of Crimea or about mh 17.
That plane that went down with Russia,
you know,
of course I had no idea what happened
and it wasn't their fault at all.
And gradually as they begin to experience
what I imagine they thought of what
success, that's when you see some of these
accounts pivot to targeting Americans.
And so in 20, late 2014, early
2015, you start to see the,
um, the strategy that for a long
time had been very inwardly focused,
making their own people think a certain
way or feel a certain way or have a
certain experience on the Internet. Uh,
it begins to spread out. It begins to, uh,
to look outwards.
And so you start to see these
accounts communicating with Americans.
And as we were going through the datasets,
which the Twitter data set is public,
anyone can go and look
at it at this point. Um,
you do see some of the accounts that
are kind of, um, you know, that were,
that were somewhat notorious for
being really virulent, nasty trolls.
I'm Andy Semitic, trolls
going after journalists. You
know, some of these accounts,
um,
being revealed as actually being a
Russian trolls now it doesn't kind of, um,
Xcel paid the actual American trolls
that were very much real and active and
part of this and expressing their opinion.
Uh,
but you do see that
they're mimicking this,
they're using that same style of tactic,
that harassment to,
to get it real people.
Then if they do get banned,
if their account gets banned,
they just simply make another
account. They use some sort of, uh,
you know, um, what is it, a virtual
virtual server? What does that call mean?
Vpns or, yeah, so if they do that,
they can kind of do that
as long as they want.
They can continue to make new accounts
and it probably also emboldens the actual
mirror controls because they're going
to go out a little bit further than
everybody else.
A little bit crazier.
And it kind of changes the
tone of discourse within
these communities that are
arguing about a certain subject.
Things get nastier and they're getting
nastier because of the interference of
these trolls.
I Gade seems like they've,
they've actually managed to not
just cause a lot of discourse,
but to change the way people were
interacting with each other and to make it
just make it more,
more vicious.
Yeah. So the, what they're doing is
they're operating in communities.
So one of the really common criticisms
of, you know, people who, um,
lot of people think that this didn't
have a huge impact. Didn't, you know,
did it swing the election?
We have no idea. Um, but the,
what it does do in the communities that
it targets is it can change that tone.
And that's where you see,
um, it's, it's, I mean,
I think everybody's probably
had this experience,
you're part of a group and then a new
person gets added to the group and the
dynamic changes. Yeah. It's very
much the same kind of thing.
Just that these are not real people
who are joining the group. Uh,
and so there's this,
um, opportunity to, to,
to,
you know,
kind of expand the bounds of tolerance
just that little bit more or try to
normalize using particular ways of
communicating that maybe a group wouldn't
naturally gravitate to.
But then it does. So there,
there are definitely a ways in which any,
any type of troll during this doesn't
have to be a Russian troll has this
ability to kind of shift the language
shift the community shifts the, uh,
the culture just a little bit.
Now, when did, why did the agency
do this and do we, do we know,
do we have someone who's ever left there
or become a whistle blower who can give
us some information about what the
mandate was and how it was carried out?
There've been a couple of a whistle
blowers and actually some investigative
journalism in Russia that's, that's
covered this. Um, they describe the,
the employees of the,
it says the Internet research agency.
So it's a little bit like a social
media marketing agency plus, um,
tactics that we would not expect a
social media marketing agency to use.
Things that are a little more like
what you would expect to see from an
intelligence agency.
So besides just making your pages
and your blogs and your social posts,
they're also in their kind of,
uh,
connecting with real people and real
activists and pretending to be something
that they're not to develop kind of a
one on one relationship, but most of the,
most of the, um, the whistle
blowers who have come out,
there's a woman named Ludmila,
Mila salvage chuck. Um,
she wrote an say I believe on this and
it's described as being much like you
would expect if you were doing
social media grunt work. Um,
you have a certain number of posts per
day. You, you know, you're driving,
trying to get a certain amount
of engagement. Um, you're trying,
you've got to kind of hit your quotas.
I'm, most people are young millennials,
the people that work there, um, they're
well versed in trolling culture.
They're well versed in internet culture.
You know,
they're up to speed on like
popular memes and things like that.
And so you do see, um, this, you know,
and then the other thing that they do is
they talk about in Mueller indictment,
you see some really interesting
descriptions of like the
standups that they have
stand is a thing you do at a tech company.
Everybody kind of stands up and you talk
about your goals and responsibilities
and blockers and things.
And in these standups they would be
sitting there saying things like, um,
if you're targeting black LGBT people,
make sure you don't use
white people in your,
in your image and your mean because that's
going to trigger them. Um, you know,
so trying to get at
the, the very niche, um,
rules for, you know, for communicating
authentically and an American community,
which is, you know, online,
you know, you sometimes, um,
there are very specific ways in which
a community expects a member of that
community to communicate.
And so they are in there and you can read
in these filings by Mueller's team and
by the Eastern District
of Virginia. Um, the, the,
the degree of granularity that they have
to recognize that if you are running a
black LGBT page and your
meme is of white people,
you're going to cause some tension and
consternation and assuming that that's
not necessarily what you want to be doing,
you should go find the meme of black
LGBT people to put in the, you know, to,
to put as your meme for the
day. So there's a lot of, um,
there's a lot of sophistication,
there's a lot of understanding of
American culture and then there's a lot of
understanding of trolling culture.
And so these things combined to be
a rather effective, uh, you know,
very effective social media agency.
Then is there an overwhelming sort of
narrative that they're trying to pursue?
The trying to push?
Yeah,
so what we saw, so I did the, um,
I did some of the research for the
Senate and the Senate data came from the
platforms. So what I had was, um, the
attribution was made by the platforms.
It wasn't like Renee deciding
this was IRA. It was the
platforms giving it to, uh,
to our government.
And the
information in there.
Um,
what it showed was that
across all platforms, across
Twitter, across Facebook,
Instagram, youtube, they
were building up tribes.
So they were really working to create
distinct communities of distinct types of
Americans. And that would be, for example,
there's an LGBT page that is very
much about LGBT pride. There is,
and they created it, they curated
and they create it, curate it.
Um, it has a, you know,
there, it's like a persona.
A lot of the posts on the LGBT page were
written by what sounded kind of like a
millennial lesbian was the voice.
Um, so it was a lot of, um, you know,
memes of LGBT actresses and they
would brand it with a specific brand.
Market was a rainbow heart. Um, uh,
LGBT United was the name of the page.
It had a matching Instagram account,
which you would also expect to
see from a media property. Right.
You would expect them to see in
both places. And this, um, you know,
they're red liga or like a, a
young woman talking about, um,
crushes on actresses and things. Actually,
you know, it was, it was, it was really,
besides the sometimes walking English
virtually indistinguishable from what you
had read on any kind of like
young millennial focused, um,
social page.
It wasn't,
none of it was radical or divisive.
It wasn't like,
um,
the way that they got the division
across was they built these tribes where
they're reinforcing in group dynamics.
So you have the LGBT page,
you have a numerous pages
targeting the black community.
That was where they spent most of their
energy. A lot of pages targeting, um,
far right? So, uh, both
old far right, meaning, um,
people who are very concerned about what
does the future of America look like.
And then young, far right,
which was much more angry,
much more like trolling culture.
So they recognize that there's a divide
there that the kinds of memes you're
gonna use to target younger,
right wing audiences are not the same
kinds of memes are going to use to target
older right wing audiences. So there's
a tribe for older rightwing younger,
right wing and the black community.
There's a baptist tribe,
there's a black liberation tribe,
there's a add black women tribe,
there's one for people who have
incarcerated spouses. There's a, uh,
Brown,
I'm Brown.
Power I believe was the name of it page
that was very much about Mexican and
Chicano culture. There was native
Americans United I, all of these are fake.
All these are fake. And what are
they trying to do with all these?
So you build up this in group dynamic
and over, and I did this over years.
So this was not a short term thing.
They started these pages and 20, 14, 20,
15 timeframe, most of them, um,
they started some other ones that
were much more political later.
And we can talk about the election if you
want to, but with this tribal thing, um,
you're building up tribe. So you're
saying like as black women in America,
this is, um, here's posts about
things that we care about.
Here's posts about black hair,
here's posts about child rearing,
here's posts about fashion and culture.
And then every now and then there would
be a post that would reinforce like as
black people, we don't do this. And so,
or as LGBT people we don't like this.
And so you're building this rapport.
So like me and you were
having a conversation,
we're developing a relationship
on this page over time.
And then I say like as this kind
of person, we don't believe this.
So it's a way to subtly influenced
by appealing to an ingroup dynamic or
appealing to like as members
of this tribe, as LGBT people.
Of course we hate Mike
Pence as black people.
Of course we're not going to vote because,
you know,
we'd hate Hillary Clinton because
we hate her husband as, um,
as people who are concerned about the
future of America is Texas assumptionists
you know, so, so everything is
presented as members of this tribe.
We think this as members of this tribe,
we don't think this,
that's why you see the,
I had a lot of,
the posts were not even political.
They were just sort of affirming
the standards of the tribe. Yes.
So they were kind of setting
up this whole long game. Yep.
And then once they got everybody on
board or how many followers are these,
do these pages have?
So the, there was kind of
a long tail. There were um,
I think 88 pages on Facebook and 133
Instagram accounts. And I would say maybe
30 of the Facebook pages had
over a thousand followers,
which is not very many.
And then, um, maybe the top 10
had upwards of 500,000 followers.
So there's, you know, same way
you run any social campaigns.
Sometimes you have hit,
sometimes you have flops. Right.
And what was interesting with the flops
as you would see them repurpose them so
they would decide, you know, the same way
if you're running a social media agency,
well we've got this audience,
this page isn't doing so well.
It's like rebrand it a little
bit, change it up, try to, um,
try to make it appeal to somebody else.
So you, so you do see this, there is a,
there is,
um,
I got this data set and I was going
through these Instagram memes and you 130,
3000 of them.
And I was um,
there was a cluster of
images of Kermit the frog.
I was like, what the hell
is Kermit the frog doing in
here? And so I, so then I go,
so this,
the,
the way the platforms provide the data
is I got like a CSV of the posts and then
I got a folder of the images.
And so in order to like connect the dots,
I had to have the image up on one screen.
And the,
this I'm thinking to the CSP up
on the other screen, CSV. Uh,
it's like a spreadsheet. Okay. Yeah.
And I turned it into a database that
we could track things a little bit more
easily across the platforms. But, um,
so I have this cluster
of Kermit the frog memes.
And I go and I look
and I realize that the,
they're attributed to an account
called army of Jesus. And I thought,
well that's interesting because you know,
these are,
some of them are really Raunchy. It was
like, it was like Kermit Miss Piggy,
like you know, I mean it was just like,
like stupid, a stupid crappy memes.
Um, attached to army of Jesus and
like the hell is going on here.
I keep going through it.
Hundreds of Kermit memes and then I
get to a post where they say like, um,
this page is owned by homer Simpson.
Now Kermit went to jail for being like,
I don't know,
they made some like some joke,
it was stupid and all of a sudden the
data set turns into homer Simpson memes.
So again, like this kind of
Raunchy homer Simpson culture, um,
and again, it's attributed to
army of Jesus. And then, yeah,
go through all this and realize that they
didn't get to actually making army of
Jesus a Jesus focused page
until like 900 posts in.
So the, they just renamed
the account at some point.
It used to be called nuts news.
And then they nuts news was what they
called it when it was the Kermit the frog
meme page. And then it gets repurposed
when they realize Kermit's not doing it.
It's not getting the audience they want
homer Simpson's not getting the audience
or engagement they want.
And then they pivot over to Jesus and
then all of a sudden they start, you know,
the likes and,
and things start pouring in.
So what they're doing is they're actually
like either deliberately or they're
just creating placeholders.
Um,
it's kind of a red flag when a brand
new account that was created yesterday
suddenly starts talking about some highly
politically divisive thing or whatever.
But if you lay the groundwork and
you do it over a period of two years,
then somebody who goes and checks
to see what the account was,
where it came from,
how old it is,
is going to see something
that was two years old.
So it's an opportunity to create almost
like sleeper accounts where you create
them now and then you activate them,
you politicize them,
you actually put them to use a
couple of years in the future.
So we saw all kinds of, uh, you know,
we, we saw this over and over again.
There was a black guns matter account
that turned into an anonymous account at
one point. Um, they were pretending to be
anonymous, you know, the hacktivist. Yeah.
So, so they repurpose this black guns
matter page, which just had, it was,
it was advocating that black people buy
weapons and carry and it was like a pro
second amendment page,
but for the black community.
And they took that page
when it wasn't getting,
I guess a ton of engagement and
it became a, it was called, um,
oh gosh, I don't remember the
exact name of the anonymous page.
And I don't want to say it was
something that's legit, but, but ah,
they pivoted into an anonymous page.
And when they do that,
do they go back and repurpose the
con the content of the earlier posts?
Do they change? That was not
clear. That wasn't clear.
We didn't get that information
from the platforms. Um,
there was a lot of stuff that I
would've loved to have insight into.
We could see again,
you know,
you'd think if you started following
an army of Jesus page and yet all this
Raunchy Kermit shit from like a year
ago that would raise some flags.
I would assume that they scrubbed
it and restart it. But I don't know
your podcast with Sam changed how I look
at a lot of the pages that I actually
follow cause I follow some pages like
that have classic cars or something like
that. And then I'll see them in, most
of it is just photographs of cars,
like beautiful cars and it'll have,
you know,
they'll have a giant following and
then all of a sudden something will get
political and I'll, I'll
look at it and go, oh wow.
Like this is probably one
of those weird accounts.
Like they're getting people to get
engaged with it because it represents
something that they're interested in,
like classic muscle cars and then they
use it for activism and they use it for,
to,
to get this narrative across.
I think I, I mean I've seen it
happen with some of mine too. Um,
I think one of the challenges is like,
you want people to be aware
that this stuff exists,
but you don't want them to be
paranoid that it's everywhere.
I know that's a problem.
I look at this all day long and
sometimes I see things and I'm like,
[inaudible] what are the odds? Um,
but, and I, and I try to, you know,
not feel like, you know, you know what,
I'm like filmmaker in some like Tom
Clancy novel. But yeah, the, um, it's,
it's this balance between when
you make people aware of it,
and I think people deserve to be aware,
but they deserve to
understand how this plays out.
The flip side of that is you do
wind up in these weird, you know,
you see it happen on
social media now, or, um,
click into a Trump tweet and you'll
see like, you're a Russian Bot. No,
you're a Russian Bot. Know you're like,
they're probably not rushing pots.
You know, it's in everybody who don't,
like on the Internet is not a Russian Bot.
Yeah,
exactly.
And so that's where you get at
the interesting conversations of,
you know, in some ways
getting caught. This is,
this is one of the challenges with running
disinformation campaigns, right? It,
it makes it really hard for people to
know what's real after the fact that it
leaves you a little bit off balance,
right? Feel like, um, you know,
when
you feel like you can't quite tell
what's real and that's part of the goal,
right? It's to make you not have a,
not feel entirely balanced and, um,
and your information environment
is this real? Is this not?
And so in some ways there's not
much downside to doing this right,
because you do,
you know,
if you either knock it out of the park
and you influenced the election and you
influence people and you have this secret
covert operation going on for years,
um, or you get caught and
then there's a, you know,
until there's some confidence and the
ability of platforms to detect this stuff,
there's real concern among everybody
that, um, that you're either,
you're encountering something
fake. Now, the overwhelming
narrative is that the Russians were
very much invested in having Trump win.
Right.
And if they were very much invested in
having Trump win was the reason why they
focus so heavily on the African American
community because the African American
community traditionally
seems to vote Democrat.
So they were trying to do something to
break that up or trying to do something
to weaken the position
of the, the, you know,
the incumbent or a Hilary Clinton and
maybe put some emphasis on Jill Stein or
some alternative candidates.
Yeah. So the, the way that
the political campaign,
the political aspect of it played out.
So they established,
they started building these relationships
in 2015 and yeah, they're doing this,
this tribal thing. We've got our
ingroup are part of this community.
And then what you start to see them
do is, um, early, they're actually,
there was a tiny,
tiny cluster in the early primaries
where they were supporting rand Paul and
then they pivot to Trump pretty
quickly and use, I'm probably ran,
Paul just didn't pull
well and they were like,
there's no way to get any lift here. But,
but maybe Trump was getting, you know,
some actual lift in the media. And so, so
you see them move into supporting Trump,
and then for the remainder of the
Dataset for it from 2015 through the end,
which was mid 2017 or so, is
when this thing ends. Um, it's,
it's adamantly pro Trump on
the right and on the right.
And you see not only pro Trump,
but you see them really working to
like a road support for mainstream or
traditional Republicans,
traditional conservatives.
You see a lot of the memes about like,
um,
are you with the Conservatives are
the Conservatives and there, you know,
and so the Conservatives
of course, her, like,
they've got pictures of
like Lindsey Graham and John
Mccain, the, Hey John Mccain,
John Mccain shows up a million
times. Um, and, uh, Marco Rubio,
Ted Cruz. Well, I think that they,
you know, one of the theories is,
um, and, and I believe
this is probably true.
They really strongly disliked Hillary
Clinton because there was concern that she
would,
you know,
things that she was saying about
increasing freedoms in Russia were very
threatening. Uh, they thought the best bet
to get sanctions removed was Trump. Um,
so they had specific outcomes that they
were hoping for. And that was one of,
you know, so there's always
like a political motivation.
So there is this narrative around they
just want to kind of like screw with
American society, create
divisions, amplify divisions.
When you look at the political content,
the clear and,
and sustained support for Trump.
And even more than that,
the clear disdain for Hillary Clinton.
There is not on Facebook and Instagram,
there was not one single pro Hillary post.
There were some anti Trump posts.
Because if you're running an LGBT page,
of course they're going to say negative
things about Trump, you know, and,
and they're saying it. So you should vote
for Jill Stein. There was early support,
um, and some of the left leaning
pages for Bernie Sanders,
but you actually see the support for
Bernie Sanders come in more after it
becomes clear that he's not going to
win because then they're using Bernie
Sanders as a way to say this was stolen
from him by the evil Clintons or Jill
Stein. You know, here's a true, a
true independent, real liberal, uh,
we should be voting for her
if we want to support a woman.
So there these feminism pages really
pushing this narrative of Jill Stein.
So you have the left leaning pages,
totally anti Clinton,
and then you have the right leaning pages,
staunchly pro Trump,
and also strongly anti cruise,
Anti Rubio, a anti Lindsey Graham,
basically ante every now what's
called establishment Republican. Um,
and there's this,
uh,
kind of pushing of people two opposite
opposite ends of the political spectrum.
So this is where you get
at the conversation around
facilitating polarization.
So not just, um, it,
it wasn't enough to just
support Donald Trump.
It was also necessary
to strongly disparage,
um,
the kind of traditional conservative,
moderate center right in the course
of amplifying the Trump candidacy.
Does that make sense? Yes, it
does. And it was a lot of stuff.
Yeah, it is a lot of stuff,
but it does make sense.
And one of the things that was really
bizarre to me watching the election and I
was trying to figure out is this because
Trump is so bombastic and he's so
outrageous and he's just a
different person that the,
the way I was describing it on stage was
that like finally the assholes have a
king because they never had a king before.
Like everyone who was running for
president was at least mostly dignified.
I mean basically it's really difficult
to go back in time and find someone who
isn't going to find someone who,
there's no one who insults
people like he does.
I mean he insults people's appearances.
He calls them losers.
He called stormy Daniels Horseface.
I mean he said some outrageous shit.
So part of it was me thinking like, wow,
maybe he's just ignited and embolden.
I actually had this conversation
with my wife today. She was like a,
it feels like racism is more prevalent.
Like it's more,
it's more accepted. People feel more
emboldened because they're in their mind,
they think he is a racist. I can get away
with more things. Trump is president.
Like there's actually videos of people
saying racist Shit and saying, hey,
Trump's president, now we can
do this. So I was thinking that,
well maybe that's what it was,
is just sort of like some rare flower
that only blooms under the right
conditions. Poof, it's back. Right?
But when you think about the influence
that these pages have had in establishing
communities and this long
game that they're playing,
like the LGBT pages,
even though they're shitting on Trump,
they really want to support Jill Stein
because they know that I'll actually help
Trump because it'll take votes away
from Hillary Clinton that they,
it seems different like
political discourse discussions
online and social media,
the way social media reacted.
I mean,
there's a lot of people that were anti
Obama, uh, before me. No, me either,
either of his election, he
won, but it seemed different.
It seemed different to me than this one.
This one seemed like,
like we had moved into another level of
hostility that never experienced before
and another level of division between
the right and the left that I had never
experienced before. And, uh,
up like a willingness to
engage with really harsh,
nasty comments and just to dive into it,
you would see it all day.
I mean there's,
there's certain Twitter followers that I
think they're pretty much human beings,
but I would follow them and they would
just be engaged with people all day long
just shitting on people and
criticizing this and insulting that.
And it seemed like it seemed dangerous.
It seemed like things had moved
into a much more aggressive,
much more hostile and confrontational
sort of chapter in American history.
If this is all done at the same
time that this is happening,
w how much of an influence do you think
this IRA agency had on all this stuff?
That's the,
uh,
that's the question that we would all
like the answer to and I unfortunately
can't give it. And so in your
mind though, yeah, let me, let me,
let me kind of caveat that.
Um,
the thing that we don't have that nobody
who looks at this on the outside has,
is we can't see what people
said in response to this stuff.
So I've looked at now almost
200,000 of these posts,
um, as what I spent most of last year
doing was, was this, was this research,
and we can see that they have
thousands of engagements,
thousands of comments,
thousands of shares.
We have no idea what happened afterwards.
And that's the problem.
So when once the stuff comes down,
it's really hard to go
back and piece it together.
So I can see that there are some,
uh, per your point, the really,
really just fucking horrible
troll accounts that they ran.
They didn't necessarily have a lot of
followers, but you see them in there,
like adding people, so
they're, you know, at,
and then the name of a reporter
at the name of a prominent person.
And so they're in their kind of like
draft on the popularity of, you know,
famous people basically. Um, and
they're just saying like horrible shit
and it's,
the tone is so spot on.
And one thing that was interesting with
a couple of them is like if you go and
you look at their profile information,
which was also made public,
they would have like, um, they would
have like a gab account in their,
in their profile that was
like, so they would, um,
so it was a remarkable piece of,
of,
of kind of the culture
in which you see that.
Like they're actually sitting on Gab too,
right.
And so they can also go and they can
draw on there and read it. And there's,
you know,
900 or something,
a troll accounts were found
on reddit there on tumbler.
And so they're just picking
the most divisive content
and they're pushing it out
into communities. And at the same
time we can see that they're doing it,
but we can't see what people do in
return. We can't see, did they just block?
Did they have the fight back?
Did, was there a huge, you know,
when this happens on a Facebook page,
um,
and they're doing something like
telling black people not to vote, um,
as black people, we shouldn't vote.
Um, what do people say in response?
And that's the piece that we don't have.
So when we talk about impact,
a lot of the impact
conversation is really uh,
focused on did this swing the election?
We don't have nothing that I've seen
has the answer to that question. Um,
the other thing is, but the
second question, the thing
when I think about impact,
I think from, from, I think
you and I agree on this, um,
it also matters how does this change
how people relate to each other.
And we have no real evidence of
no information on that either.
This is the kind of thing that lives
in some, you know, Facebook has it,
the rest of us haven't seen it.
No. Are Most of these people,
is this mostly Facebook? Is it
mostly Twitter or where, what is,
how does it break down?
Yeah, so there were, um,
here am I like little stats here cause
that would give you the wrong data.
There were 10 and a half million tweets
of which about 6 million were original
content created by about 3,800 accounts.
Um,
there were about 133,
I me just read it,
133 Instagram accounts with about 116,000
posts and then 81 Facebook pages and
17 youtube channels with
about 1100, um, videos.
And so they got about 200
million engagements on
Instagram and about another 75
million or so on Facebook. Um, engagements
are like, likes, shares, comments,
reactions, you know, um, so
it's hard to contextualize what,
what we think happened, you know,
you can go and you can try to look at,
um,
how well did this content perform
relative to other real authentic media
targeting these communities.
And what you see with the black community
in particular is their Instagram game
was really good. Um, they're, so
they're on their Instagram accounts,
the, you know, the top five, three of
them targeted the black community and got,
you know, tens, 200
millions of engagements.
So I would have to pull up
the exact numbers off the
top of my head. Yeah. It's,
um, it's on Instagram. It's
all memes and then you know,
so we have the memes and then
we have the text on Instagram.
You can't really share.
So it's amazing that they got the
kind of engagement that they did.
Even without the sharing function.
One of the things you can do is if you
know the names of the accounts and there
a lot of them are out there publicly now,
um,
you can actually see them
in regram apps. So, uh,
people were regramming the content.
So Facebook says about 20 million people,
excuse me,
engaged with the Instagram content,
but what isn't included in that is all
of the re grams of the content that were
shared by other accounts.
So the spread and the dispersion of this.
It's an interesting,
uh,
interesting thing to try to quantify
because we have engagement data,
but we don't know,
did it change hearts and minds?
We don't know if it influenced
people to go follow other accounts.
people to not vote. Uh,
there's just so much more,
I think still to,
to understand about how these
operations work. Well, we can kind of,
we can assume that it had some
impact, right? I mean, yes, as,
as you were saying earlier, when a
new person enters into a conversation,
it changes the tone of it.
How much of what they did was their own
original post and how much of it was
commenting on other people's posts.
So I thought you're actually going
to ask a different thing there.
How much of it was then
repurposing our own posts, right.
Repurposing real American content.
Um, did they do that as well? Yeah,
tons of times. But let me, let me, uh,
so they created a lot of their own stuff,
particularly in the early days.
And so you can actually read the Dataset.
And one of the things when we
started finding these posts,
I was struck by how sometimes it read
like Esl and then sometimes it red lake,
perfect, flawless, um,
professional English.
And then other times it read
like normal English vernacular.
Just the way that we
would talk to each other.
And I started digging into what that was.
So when it was vernacular
English, when it was, when it,
when it read like fluent American
American English, it was, um,
usually cribbed from somewhere else.
So they would go and they would find a
local news story from some obscure local
paper and they would crib and then
they would paste that. And then,
so the Facebook posts would be that
cribbed a sentence from that article and
then their meme,
ah,
maybe they would add a sentence underneath
it to give it some kind of context or
angle. When they would write their own
stuff, you would see the sloppiness.
That's where you could see, um, subject
verb agreement is not quite there. The,
you know,
ways in which like Russian possessives
are different than American possessives
the slips there. Um, and then the
other thing was the really funny stuff,
which was, um, you know,
a post that's supposed to supposedly
written by a Texas secessionist, right?
So you can probably have an image of a
Texas secessionists in your mind as I say
this. And it would be things like, um,
Hillary Clinton is a terrible
individual and as a, uh,
as a terrible individual,
it's completely impossible for us to back
her in her candidacy for the American
presidency. Furthermore, you know what
it's like, furthermore, air go, you know,
it is clear that, and I'm
like, it reads like memory.
You're like in English in college or
something and you got to like write a
formal essay. I was like, all right,
so nobody actually talks like
that, especially not, you know,
your gear stereotypical Texas is
Ashiana. So it was funny seeing these,
um,
incongruities and that's unfortunately
one of the best ways to tell what you're
dealing with is actually to kind of look
for those incongruities now and see ya
as you read communications
online, like, can, you know,
does this,
does this read like an American,
does this read like a communication?
And what we started to see was one way
to not get caught for your lousy English
or you're, you know, yeah.
How your cultural, um,
lack of, uh, kind of native, native, um,
abilities is to just repurpose
other people's stuff.
And so that's where you would see
memes getting shared from, uh,
on both the right and the left.
You know,
you'd see a lot of these like turning
point USA members that they were
repurposing and pushing
out or you would see, um,
occupied Democrats or the other 98%.
So memes from real American pages,
real American culture.
And they would just sometimes slap a new
logo on and just repost it as if it was
theirs. So it does in those
instances read just like, you know,
authentic American content. And in many
ways it is authentic American content.
How many people were
working for this agency?
I don't remember off the
top of my head. It was, um,
somewhere between a couple
hundred, a thousand, I think.
I don't know if it's bigger than that.
They're just,
they just moved offices and um, it's
a funny story. I guess they, um,
moved offices and then people started
calling in bomb threats to the office and
it was just like every day a new bomb
threat would get called on so they
couldn't work.
Basically.
I assume this is like some American
intelligence agency just like fucking with
them,
but just people calling in these bomb
threats to try to keep them from working.
And I think,
um,
there was an article that came out
really recently that said that like army
cyber or one of our, uh, one of
our agencies work to just like, um,
take them offline during the,
during the midterms,
couple of days around the midterms.
I wonder if whoever's calling and then
is doing it and bad Russian. Yeah.
Be So ironic because I was really funny,
like move to the right,
nice new office building on someone
chucked a Molotov cocktail through the
window at some point. Like
of course, yeah, of course.
Versus spy. Yeah. I mean,
it only makes sense that in this
bizarre and unpredictable and really
unprotected, unprecedented
environment that we find ourselves in,
that something like this would come up
and just sort of throw a monkey wrench
into the gears of,
of real conversation online.
I mean it's,
it's a really amazing time in that
we're getting to see this kind of stuff
happen in real time. We're,
we're getting to see these,
these sort of weird attempts
at manipulating things.
And I think in a lot of the successful,
especially with less sophisticated
people that don't really understand that
they're being trolled and that someone
fucking with them. And there's, it seems,
I mean I've,
there's a bunch of accounts that
I have bookmarked that I follow,
but I don't follow.
So I don't follow them online lungs,
I don't want them to know I'm following.
I'm going to just go to them.
And some of them are so strange,
a few of them are flat earth accounts.
This is something that I'm finding
the conspiracy theorists. Yes.
And some of them literally have almost,
no,
it's all memes and they don't say much.
If anything underneath the memes
and I go to it, I'm like, what?
What exactly are they doing here?
Like what exactly are they trying
to do with these? Because they just,
they're very weird.
There was one that I came across,
um, I was looking at the, uh, the,
the conversation around Gmos and because
we have seen one of the things that
Russia does besides the social bots and
the, you know, the amount, you know,
screen with like Americans
directly, um, is the house.
So this was a Republican House
committee. The House, uh,
science and technology committee about
a year ago said that they were seeing
evidence of,
um,
both kind of overt propaganda
and then ways of, um,
disseminating the propaganda.
So there's always the dissemination and
then the account and then the content.
So it's like you look at three different
things to try to get a handle on
whether or not this is real or fake.
Um,
so when we talk about the
accounts we're looking at,
are they real people or they, you know,
automated, are they not automated?
When you're looking at the content,
you're usually looking at the domains. Um,
and that's kind of the last piece,
cause you don't want to have
any kind of bias get in there,
but you're just trying to see is it
being pushed through like overt Russian
propaganda domains,
like their think tanks and things.
And then the third is the
dissemination pattern.
Is it being pushed out
through automated accounts?
Is it spreading in ways that
look anomalous versus how
normal information would
spread.
So one of the things that the house
committee looked at was using that kind of
rubric. Um, Russian, uh, you know,
these dubious,
um,
pieces of content and narratives
around American strategic industries.
So the energy industry, oil and
fracking for example, or the, um,
uh, you'd see a lot of stuff
with, um, Gmos and agriculture.
You know, this is very,
his narrative of, um, you know, Putin
and Russia being the land of organic,
plenty in the United States, a serving
it's people, toxic poisoned vegetables,
this, the sort of stuff. And
meanwhile, at the same time,
there's competition for who's
going to get the, you know,
large contract to provide rice
to some part of the world. So,
so there's like an economic motivation
underlying this, this kind of narrative.
And I was looking at one of these accounts
and it was tweeting and article about
Hillary Clinton.
A vote for Hillary is a vote for Monsanto,
but it was tweeting this in, you know,
just like three months ago or something.
It was like mid 2018 or late 2018
when I was at this. I'm like,
well that ship sailed a long
time ago guys, why are we,
why are we tweeting about,
you know, Hillary's vote just because
they just, they're just there to,
it was written by a Russian think tank.
And so they're,
they just have these
automated accounts retweeting,
repurposing this content from forever
ago. And it, it doesn't even make sense,
it's just out there to amplify a
particular point of view or bump up, uh,
mentions of the site. What were they
trying to do with the Anti vaccine posts?
Yeah, that was a, that
was an interesting thing.
So I would say not much to be honest.
Um,
the,
there were 900,
maybe 800, I think, um, tweets
about vaccines in the content.
And so Facebook and Twitter,
you have this, uh, sorry,
Facebook and Instagram. You have this
building up of tribes. Twitter you have,
instead they're just talking
about whatever is popular, right?
They're talking to her shit posting.
They're talking about whatever's current,
new whatever scandal has just
broken anywhere. And you know, um,
so Twitter is less about establishing
relationships and more about joining the
conversation and nudging it.
And so most of the vaccine related posts,
it was not a big theme for them.
It wasn't something that was on like
Facebook and Instagram where that's where
they're really leaning in. Like, this is
what we want Americans to think about.
So no mention of vaccines on those
platforms. Not on Youtube, on Twitter.
You see it in 2015. Funny enough, during
the Disneyland measles outbreak, um,
much like there's a whole
lot of conversation around
vaccines right now because
of the outbreaks in
Washington in New York. Uh,
back in 2015 you saw the same thing,
lots of conversations about measles
because the Disneyland thing that happened
down here. And so they're in there and
they're saying, I'm vaccinate your kids.
Don't vaccinate your kids. They had a
couple of conspiracy theorist accounts.
Um, I am trying to remember
the name. It was a,
it looked like a blonde woman. I
think it's name was Amy. Um, and uh,
Amy was a, was a conspiracy
theorists. Amy was a fake person.
Yeah. I wish I could remember
his Twitter account. Um,
God, what the Hell was her name?
She Wa Amy Black. Um, there,
there are certain of the certain of their
personas actually got a lot of lift.
There was one called Woke Louisa that
was a black woman. There was a, yeah,
I mean they nail it right then
and there. They're not dumb. Um,
there was 10 GOP,
the fake Tennessee GOP page.
How much autonomy do you think these
people have that are creating these things
are the, it sounds like some of them
are actually pretty funny. Yeah,
they're funny. They're funny. That's why
they work. That's what everybody thinks.
It's just like, you know, in competent
shit, it's not, it's actually really good.
That's where that, that's, I
think the thing that, you know,
even with, um, whatever, you know,
political proclivities you may have,
I think you can at least recognize humor
even if it's laughing at your side.
And I will say that some of the
stuff, especially the, the right wing,
you know, the right wing, like youth
kind of pages where they were funny,
they really work.
And it was,
I think that is, people assume that
like they're too smart to fall for it.
Um, it's just those liberals or it's
just those conservatives or you know, uh,
it's, it's really, it,
it targets everybody and they
understand the psychology,
the motivation,
the narratives and the culture and
they produce the content accordingly.
And I imagined that they had a grand old
time doing it because there were some
stuff and, um, two narratives
that came out in 2017,
um, the first was when Facebook
started to moderate their pages,
they started to scream about
how Facebook was censoring them.
So the exact same narrative that you
see today about how any moderation is
censorship. It's, you know, a picture of
like Zuckerberg. And it's like, nice page.
You've got to be a shame if
anything happened to it, you know,
and that's the meme that they're putting
out there when they're complaining that
they're fake. Page got taken
down. Um, there was, uh,
tons and tons of these memes also about,
um,
the Russians did it mocking the
idea that the Russians did it. Uh,
so this is as the story is beginning
to come out before we've had the tech
hearings before we've had the Mueller
indictment's before we've had the
investigation, you see these memes, um,
where it's like, oh, my
speedometer was broken.
It must've been the Russians
or picture of Hillary Clinton.
And it's like a in a like little
golden book kind of thing.
And it's like the whiny child's guide
to blaming Russia for your failures.
You know, and it's, again, it's funny,
like the stuff is funny and they're
like Metta trolling and you imagine them
sitting there like, you know, they have
a picture of like some like, you know,
buff guy carrying a gun and they're like,
I'm not a Russian troll man.
I'm an American. Wow. Okay.
So you're looking at this and you're
like, it's just so spot on. And again,
I can't see what the people commented
under it if they were like right on or if
they were like, ah, this is bullshit.
But so that's where you get at the,
they, it's, you know,
people think like, Oh,
I'm too smart to fall for it, or Oh,
this is targeting those other people. No,
it isn't. That's the
problem. It's just, um,
it's going to target you with the thing
that you're most likely to be receptive
to just because of psychological bias
and tribal affiliation and you're not
sitting there thinking,
how is this person who is purportedly
just like me screwing with me?
And that's why,
uh,
that's why it does manage to attract a
following and get retweeted, get reshared.
Um,
it's good.
Well, it's so clever because
it's so comprehensive.
There's so much involved in it and the
fact that they're willing to do this for
years and years before they really sort
of activate the political aspect of what
they're trying to do. It also, it's,
it's strange that they're so sophisticated
about our culture because we don't
know a goddamn thing about Russia.
The average person knows Putin, bad,
evil, warlord, Crimea, he
invade. You know, like we, we,
we have like a four year olds
understanding. Like if you had a,
if you just grabbed a person,
random person that's true,
college educated person and ask them to
describe what's so bad about Russia. Wow.
It's like communist over
there or something man. Me,
they fucking, they hate us.
First of all,
they have bombs like this.
There's so little
understanding of their culture,
but yet they know so much about hours.
That's one of the weird things about
being an American. When you go,
when you travel overseas and you realize
how much they know about our elections,
how much they know,
we don't even know who the fuck
there was running their country.
We don't have any idea,
but they know about Trump and they know
that Hillary did this and they know that
Bernie wants to give the money away. And
you know, it's, it's crazy. It's, it's,
it's weird.
And these people must have
like a deep education on, uh,
American culture, American politics. Do
you think they're training these kids?
Yeah,
absolutely.
I would.
So they did a couple things that
came out in the Mueller indictment.
First of all,
a couple of people actually came here
and did a road trip around America.
Oh. Literally just to
learn when to Texas? Yeah.
Like basically telling me where you
keep the beef jerky. But that's a,
that was in the, uh, one of the, I
think the Mueller indictment of a,
from February 28 teen,
there've been three kind of big documents
that have come out to from eastern
district and one from Mueller
on, um, on how it all worked out.
I think another misconception is
this notion of $100,000 in ads.
They spent $18 million in 2017,
I believe was the stat that came out
during another one of the Mueller
indictment's. So they're
not just, you know,
the money's not just going for
the salaries and the ad buys.
The money's also going for, um, they were
talking about using kind of consultants.
And this is where you get at this thing
that comes out during the standup or
they're like black people who are LGBT
don't want to see white LGBT memes and,
and this degree of granularity,
the degree of sophistication.
But then also what you see them doing is
engaging one on one and that's where it
crosses the line from social media
operation to this as much more like,
uh, like spying. You want to watch the
Americans no idea. Oh, I love that show.
You should definitely go to that. Great.
It's great. It's too many things to watch.
Totally. But what's
interesting is the, um, it,
it does paint a pretty interesting
picture of like this, um,
this couple under deep cover that are
engaging with and pretending to be
Americans and forming relations.
Jen, apparently it's based
loosely on real people. Yeah.
That's what I've read also.
But what you see in the, um,
in the Mueller indictment is the
text messages is the messenger,
the Facebook messenger messages where
they're going back and forth with real
activists and they're saying
things like, um, you know, hey,
my ad account got shut down.
Can you run some ads for me
or the, um, hey, I want
to help your protest. Um,
we're fellow black lives matter activists
and we see you're running a protest up
and I think it was like
Ethica or something. Um,
Binghamton. How can we help you?
We can give you some money for posters
and they're sending money for posters or
they reach out to a Trump
supporter and they say like,
we think it'd be really funny to have a
Hillary Clinton impersonator sitting in
a truck flatbed truck that's made
up to look like a jail. Let us, um,
and if we give you some money, will you
find the Hillary Clinton impersonator?
And, um, put her in Jalan do
this Hillary for prison thing.
And so this is where another
thing that they did was, um,
using Facebook events to create real
world protests so they're not limiting it
to shit, posting online and
making people feel tension online.
They're actually sending people out
into the real world to have in street
violence.
And so one of the things that they did
was they coordinated Facebook event, um,
one for the Texas secessionist page.
And one for the,
there was a pro Muslim called
United Muslims. And on the same day,
at the same time in Texas,
they have a rally to support,
um,
Texas culture and resist
the Islamicization of Texas
across the street from a
rally to defend Muslim
culture. And so they, like,
there's literally no, they just create
these Facebook events on these pages and,
and then they promote them with
ad dollars and other things. And,
and you literally, if you go and you look
at the Texas reporting from that day,
um, I don't remember if
it was dozens or hundreds,
but a sufficient number of people showed
up that they had literally on opposite
sides of barricades,
police officers in this center screaming
at each other because one group is
there for the resists,
the Islamization of Texas,
and the other group is there to like
defend Muslim culture. And so you get to,
you know, two opposite sides
of the spectrum in the same
place at the same time.
And you literally insight like
a mini riot. So they were there.
There were about 81 of these
events where they were holding, um,
black lives matter style rallies for
victims of violence, police violence, um,
memorials for people who were
killed by police officers. You know,
things that real Americans would do,
but this wasn't being done by
real Americans. And that's,
that's the insidious thing, right? Is
how does, how does Facebook detect that?
How to,
you know,
how to you when you see this come to
defend Texas culture and you're a diehard
proud Texan, you know, you're not thinking
like somebody in St Petersburg is, is,
is organizing this.
And that's the, I mean,
I think that the idea that
this was just some memes,
um,
is just not,
it doesn't respect the significance
of what they were trying to do and how
effective that they were with these
other things where even if they're just
trying it out just a little bit,
just working to see what works.
They're always experimenting.
They're always trying to find
ways to create that tension. Um,
and that's the thing that I think
is so interesting about this, right?
This evolving, this idea of an information
war where these tactics evolve,
um,
and you are really at a disadvantage
when it comes to actually detecting them.
Yeah. And on the outside, if you're
looking at that, you'd say, well, okay,
what is their objective?
Why would they have this Texas a session
as page across or rally across the
street from a pro Islam rally?
Why would they do that? You know,
if you're on the outside,
you think about the amount of effort
that's involved in doing something like
this and they are also doing
this with no leaders, right.
There's no one there that's running
it when they get there. Yeah.
So all the pro Texas people go
here we are looking over there.
So mother fucking enemy.
I think
couple times there were comments,
um,
on some of the like archived pages
and things where you could see the
screenshots of people being like, Dude,
you hell, it has all come out there.
And like nobody showed up.
Right. Who is in charge? You know,
they're probably throwing a lot of
things against the wall hoping that
seven something stacks. Will
you see this on the, um,
there was a page called black matters
and black matters was interesting cause
they went and made a whole website.
So they made a website, black matters,
you ask.com, which I think is
still active. It's dormant.
They're not updating it, but I believe
that you can go in and read it. Um,
and it was designed to call attention
to police brutality type things.
And so they had this black manners.
You ask page and then there's
the black matters Facebook page,
the Twitter account, the Instagram
page, the youtube channel,
the soundcloud podcast,
the tumbler,
the Facebook stickers.
They had Facebook stickers that look like
little black panthers. Like little, um,
little cats. Yeah, a little black
cats. They were actually really cute,
very well done.
Um,
so you have this entire fake media
ecosystem that they've just created out of
whole cloth,
all theirs.
And then what they start to do
is they start to put up job ads.
And so it's Cumbia designer for us.
Come be a, uh, come write for us,
come photograph our
protests come, um, you know,
they have like a kind of like, um, black,
I dressed in a cool outfit like hipster,
you know, holding a sign,
like join black matters. Um,
you see them go through a couple of
different logos the same way you would if
you were starting a, you
know, a media brand. Um,
they start posting ads for,
do you want to be a calendar girl?
Send us your photos and do you want
to be on a black reality TV show,
send us video clips of
you. Um, do you like,
they begin to do real work to ingratiate
themselves with the community that a
physical fitness thing. It
was called black fest. And
the idea was that it was, um,
kind of vaguely militant task.
Um,
and that it was supposed to teach a
black people how to handle themselves at
protests. Should there be police
violence had a fight back.
And they actually went and found a guy,
a physical fitness, you know, martial
guy, and they were paying
him via paypal. So, so,
so he was running classes for the black
community under this black fist, um,
brand.
And they would like text him or call him.
He played some of the voicemails
on TV. Actually I heard them, um,
after my report came out,
I think they tracked him down and um,
and he just talks about how they,
yeah, they just pay pal them, you know,
a couple hundred bucks. Every time you
run a fitness class, the voicemails,
like it was a little
concerned.
The police say you'd, you'd
be, you'd be surprised.
They actually had a youtube channel with
two black men named Williams and Calvin.
And there was this channel, Williams
and Calvin and actual book actual, yeah,
they hired these guys to
be a fake youtube channel.
Um, and it was a, it was called a word of
truth, I think was what the name of it.
And so Williams and Calvin
and these two guys would, um,
would give their word of truth and
their word of truth was usually about,
you know, how fucked up America
is, which I mean, there,
there are very real grievances underlying
all of this. And that's the problem,
right? They have things to exploit. Um,
and writing these things for these
gentlemen. I imagine. I mean,
imagine they were definitely paying
them and they organize the channel seems
likely channels organized. Yeah.
All that. That particular one,
I think that they were actually,
they were in on it.
They knew what they
were doing that because
one of the guys who was in that channel
popped up again in 2018 right before the
midterms.
Like maybe even the day before.
I'm trying to remember the timeline here.
Um,
and he made a different video saying
he wanted to, this was amazing,
saying he wanted to leave the internet
research agency kind of. So he was saying,
um, basically, um, I'm
tired of doing this work.
I want to,
I want to do a leak.
I want to show you all of the things that
the Internet research agency has done.
And so they actually put out this.
So this guy who had been in
the Williams and Calvin video,
so people recognize his face in the
2018 midterms goes and says he wants to
leave and he's going to leak
all this information and sorry,
this damn cough.
And he wants to to like confess.
I don't remember all the specifics because
it was right before my thing came out
and I was so busy
working. But um, but yeah,
he pops up again and he is saying he like
wants to expose the truth and I think
most people didn't cover it,
didn't pay attention. Youtube,
shut down the channel and deleted the
video immediately. Um, why they do that?
I think that it was seen as another
influence operation. You know,
you don't trust the,
um,
so even intention that he's going to
expose it was probably just another level.
Well, what wound up coming out, this
was, this is so convoluted. I'm sorry.
I know it's like hard to
explain without visuals. Um,
what they wound up doing was
they did drop a bunch of docs.
So they did release a pile of documents
in which they claimed they actually
hacked the Mueller investigation.
Mueller had nothing.
And so this is again, another kind of, um,
convoluted piece of this where
they do release information.
And so in this particular example,
they release information that we
believe they actually got through legal
discovery.
So the documents that the investigation
provided to one of the indicted Russians
were the documents that they then leaked
claiming they had hacked the Mueller
investigation. So they're constantly
doing these things to generate press,
generate attention, create just that
degree of people don't know what's real.
Um,
or they read the headlines that are then
released by the more propagandist overt
Russian propaganda. And they think that
that is the true story, that, that, that,
that is, um, that, that the Russians
hacked the Mueller investigation.
So there's always this, um, how do we
create fear, uncertainty and doubt?
How do we throw people off?
How do we come up with these extremely
convoluted spy games that leave people
feeling unbalanced, that make
people wonder what they can trust,
who they can trust and what's real. And
even as somebody who looks at this stuff,
you know, day in and day
out for years, um, I,
I do still regularly get surprised by the,
uh,
by the sheer kind of ballsiness
and ingenuity of, of, of, you know,
some of the stuff is it
as it comes to light?
Well,
it's really fascinating that they went
so far as to hire people to make a fake
account on youtube and hired these black
guys to pretend that they're doing that
on their own and they're really
being hired by the Russians.
And then when the guys leave, you don't
know if they really did leave. Yeah.
You don't know if this is just
more bullshit. It's like in,
like you were saying earlier, if they
get you and you buy into it, hook,
line and sinker, they win. If
they get you to think, well,
how much else is bullshit?
They still went, Yup.
Because you're looking at everything
with sort of this tainted lens now
everything seemed,
and the sense that's probably the ultimate
goal is to disrupt our social media
environment and to sort of hijack the,
the natural conversations
that are taking place.
Yeah. And I think it's, I mean, it's
effective. There's certain, you know,
I was in Estonia last year,
um,
and they've been targeted by
this stuff for decades now,
have a 25% Russian speaking population.
And most of the news that they get is
from Russian media, right. You know,
right on the border.
Um,
they talk a lot about the
extreme commitment to educating
their citizens to make
them realize that this
kind of thing does happen.
This is what it usually looks like.
Um, don't share it here. You know,
just ignore it.
Let it go by.
And I don't think we're quite there yet.
I think there's still plenty of people
in the country who don't believe it
happened.
Um,
or for some reason are completely
incapable of separating the Russian social
media influence campaign happened from
it means Donald Trump's election is a
legitimate, or it means
Donald Trump colluded, right?
Those are very different statements that
you don't have to collude in order for
someone somewhere to unsolicited
go and support your candidacy.
So you can believe two
things simultaneously. One,
that Trump did not collude and that his
election is perfectly legitimate and
that this had no impact and to that it
still happened. And that I think is, um,
I am consistently amazed when I read
my social media mentions it at how hard
that ability to hold those
two ideas is for, for people.
They just believe that if
they're supporters of Trump,
they absolutely cannot acknowledge
that this operation took place.
And I, or if they are passionate
supporters of the far left,
um, it's more of like an
equivocation, you know? Well,
we don't really know if they did it
well. The rest us bad things too. Well,
how do we know? You know,
so that's where, um, it, it,
it plays out very differently depending
on which part of the political spectrum
you sit on. Well, it
falls right into our, the
issue that we have with
cognitive dissonance.
If we believe in someone or
if we want someone to win,
especially if it's our team or our person
or on our side, you know, like I, I,
yeah,
I saw a lot of this when Donna Brazil
released her book detailing how the DNC
sort of rigged the primaries against
Bernie Sanders and, and, and for Clinton,
there was so many people
that were Clinton supporters.
It just didn't want to
believe it. I was like, well,
why wouldn't you believe this woman?
Like you believed her before when she
was supporting Clinton and then when she
leaves now you know, you won't believe
her. It's because it's inconvenient.
And we were real weird in our binary view.
We want things to be good or bad.
It was one or zero. This is it.
And this is a super complex issue.
It seems like they've been doing this
for a long time and they've gotten really
sophisticated at it.
And I think there's a lot of people that
have been sucked into it that have no
idea that it's actually
influenced the way they've,
they've formed their own opinions.
This is where it gets really strange.
People are so malleable and
they're so easily manipulated.
Many people are that something like this,
like a real good solid,
concentrated effort to try to target
these groups that have these very specific
interests and really dig in
and form roots and then go out.
I mean, it's so sophisticated.
They're their approaches.
I'm on one hand horrified and the
other hand deeply impressed. Yep.
Me Too.
Now was this freaking you out when you
had to like go over all these memes and
you were actually laughing them
and you're like, God
damn it. Well, you know,
there's the tweet that goes
around every now and then.
You don't have to hand it to them.
And I'm always like, ah, how do I, um,
how do I properly convey, uh, um,
recognition for the,
you know,
I don't think we do ourselves any favors
by pretending it all sucked and didn't
matter in they're incompetent.
I think that you have to acknowledge
that you have a sophisticated adversary
that is very capable. They're
very determined, that is
constantly evolving. Um,
and to treat that with the
degree of respect it deserves.
I think that that's just
common sense actually. Um, I,
I, I read media on both sides of
the aisle and I, I, you know, um,
I feel I try to stay current actually
on what memes are percolating in lots of
different spaces and part just because
I am always curious about what's organic
versus what seems to be disproportionately
amplified or what new communities are
popping up.
I just think it's an,
I think be spread of information
among people is just very interesting.
You know, it's, it's something
that interests me a lot.
I think crowd psychology
is really interesting.
I think ways that crowd psychology has
transformed as the Internet has kind of
come into being,
particularly with things
like the mass consolidation,
the ease with which we can target people.
You know,
we didn't even really talk about that.
But the, um, one of the things with,
there's all, you know, even
in the decentralized Internet,
there's always been propaganda. There's
always been crazy conspiracy theories,
all this stuff.
But it's that you can reach the people
who are likely to be receptive to it now
and as people self select into tribes,
particularly in this country right now.
Um,
one of the things that's remarkable
is the way in which once you've self
selected into that tribe and this is the
media in your ecosystem and you share
it with your friends and Facebook and
that the people who see it are the people
who are most likely to be receptive to it.
Where if you run the ad
targeting you directly, you know,
send it into the feeds of people
most likely to be receptive to it.
We have this interesting phenomenon where
consolidation targeting and then these
gainable algorithms mean that it's
just this kind of information goes way
farther away,
faster than it ever could in the past,
regardless of whether it's
Russia pushing it or, um,
Iran as we've seen a, you know, a network
of Iranian pages went down recently. Um,
we see this globally now.
We see countries targeting their own
people with it and it's just this is the
information ecosystem.
This is like the new
infrastructure for speech at it.
Sorry. Privileges this kind
of sensationalist content.
Yeah. Do you have hopes?
Would be great.
Don't feel bad. Um, who's,
who's seen all this stuff?
I mean, has, obviously
Facebook has a check this out.
I'm sure Twitter's aware.
What has their reaction been and is
there any sort of a concerted effort to
mitigate some of the, some of the
impact of these these sites have?
Yeah, lots of it actually.
So I think, um, in,
in 2017 was when we started,
like we being independent researchers,
I guess people on the outside
of the company's academics, um,
began to find the content,
you know,
really began to investigative journalists
would identify the name of a page and
then me and people like me would go and
we would scour the Internet looking for
evidence of what was on that page. So I
found a bunch of the stuff on Pinterest,
for example, wrote about it. Um, guy
by the name of Jonathan Albright, uh,
found a crowdtangle data cache.
And with that we got the names of a
bunch more pages, bunch more posts,
and we had some really interesting
stuff to work with. Originally.
The platforms were very resistant
to the idea that this had happened.
And so as a result of that, they were, um,
in, you know, there was a,
the first thing that Zach said in
2016 when Trump gets elected Twitter,
it goes crazy that night with people
who work at Twitter saying, oh my God,
where are we responsible for this? Which
is very silicon valley thing to say. Um,
but what I think they meant by that was
their platform had been implicated as
hosting Russian bots and fake news and
harassment mobs and a number of other
things.
And there was always the sense that
it didn't have an impact and it didn't
matter. And so this was the first time
that they started to ask the question,
did it matter? And then Zach
made that statement. Um,
fake news is a very small percentage
of, you know, whatever on Facebook,
the amount of information on Facebook
and the idea that it could have swung on
election was ludicrous.
So you have the platforms,
kind of the leaders at the platforms
digging in and saying it's inconceivable
that, that, that this, you
know, could have happened.
And as the research and the discovery
begins to take place over the next nine
months or so, you, you, you get to
the one the tech hearings happen.
So I worked with, um, high by
the name of Tristan Harris.
He's the one who introduced
me to Sam. Um, and he,
he and I started going to DC with a
third fellow, Roger Mcnamee and saying,
Hey,
there's so much,
there's this body of evidence that's
coming out here and we need to have a
hearing.
We need to have congress ask the tech
companies to account for what happened,
to tell the American people what happened.
Because what we're seeing
here as outside researchers,
what investigative
journalists are writing,
the things that we're finding just
don't line up with the statements that,
that nothing happened.
And this was all no big deal.
And so we start asking for
these hearings and actually,
um, myself and a couple of others then
began asking them in the course of these
hearings,
can you get them to give you the data?
Because the platform's
hadn't given the data.
So it was that lobbying by concerned
citizens and journalists and researchers
saying,
we have to have some accountability here.
We have to have the platforms
account for what happened.
They have to tell people,
um,
because it had become such a politically
divisive issue. Did it even happen?
And we felt like having them actually sit
there in front of Congress and account
for it would be the first step towards,
um,
towards moving forward in a
way, but, but also towards
changing the minds of the public and
making them realize that what happened on
social platforms matters.
And it was,
it was really interesting to,
to be part of that as
it, as it played out. Um,
because one of the things that
Senator Blumenthal, one of the,
one of the senators said
was actually said, um,
Facebook and Twitter have to notify
people who engage with this content.
And so they are, there
was this idea that, um,
if you are engaging with
propagandas content, you
should have the right to know.
And so they started to push messages,
Twitter,
send out these emails to all these people,
um,
saying you engaged with
this Russian troll. And, um,
Facebook created a little field,
a little little page that told people if
they had liked or followed a troll page.
So it was really trying to get at making
the platform's accountable outside the
platform through email. Huh. Too.
Which is interesting because I would never
read an email that Twitter sends you.
This has just gotta be nonsense.
I didn't get one. So I maybe,
I guess I just got lucky,
but, um, I might've had a
multiple day back and forth.
It's a rush. But that was I think one
of the first steps towards saying like,
how do we make the platforms accountable?
Because the idea that platform
should be accountable was not a,
a thing that everybody agreed on in 2015
when we were having this conversation
about isis. And that's where there's
the, the through line here, which is, um,
and it does connect into some
of the speech issues too,
which is what kind of
monitoring and moderation do
you want the platforms to do.
And when we were having this
conversation about Isis, there was a, um,
not insignificant collection of voices
that were really concerned that if we
moderated isis trolls on Twitter,
they're not the beheading videos.
There were sort of universal agreement
that the beheading videos should come
down. But if we took out what were called
the Isis fanboys, which were like 30,
40,000 accounts at their
peak, um, that we would, yeah,
there's a document called the isis
Twitter census for anyone who wants to
actually see the research done on
understanding the Twitter network in 2015
there is a sense that like
one man's terrorist is
another man's freedom fighter.
And if we took down Isis fanboys,
um,
where we stifling their freedom of speech,
freedom of expression and like goodness,
what would come next.
And that when you, when
you look at that, um,
that fundamental swing that
has happened now in 2018,
2019 where those are,
is that same narrative because originally
no moderation was taking place and
then now there's a feeling that it's
kind of swung too far in the other
direction. Um, but the original
conversations were really,
how do we make Twitter take
responsibility for this?
And legally they aren't
responsible for it, right?
They are legally indemnified against the,
they're not responsible for any
of the content on their platforms.
None of the platforms are.
There is a law called communications
decency act section two 30,
and that says that
they're not responsible.
They have the right to moderate but not
the obligation to moderate because they
are indemnified from responsibility.
So the question becomes now that we know
that these platforms are used for these
kinds of harms and they are used
for this kind of interference, um,
where is that balance?
What do we want them are responsible
for monitoring and moderating and how do
we,
um,
how do we recognize that that is
occasionally going to lead to an incorrect
attribution's people losing
accounts and things like that. So
yeah, they're, they're in a
weird conundrum right now or
they don't, they, they're,
they're trying to keep everything safe
and they wanna encourage people to
communicate on the platform. So they
want to keep people from harassing folks.
But because of that, they've also,
they've got these algorithms and they,
they,
they tend to miss very often like this
whole learn decode fiasco where people
are getting banned for life
for saying learn to code,
which is about as preposterous as a guest.
I think the learn to code fiasco is going
to be the tipping point where a lot of
people in the,
in the future when they look back on,
when did the heavy
handedness become overreach,
learn to code because I mean,
Jesus Christ,
I mean that if you can't say learn to
code. I mean I look in my mentions,
I mean on any given day, especially
like yesterday I had um, uh,
a vaccine proponent. Yeah,
yeah. Peter's Great. And, and,
and you know, and it seemed like what
was really disturbing to me was like,
the vast majority of the comments were
about vaccines and so few about these
unchecked diseases that are running
rampant in poor communities,
which was the most disturbing
aspect of the conversation to me.
That there's diseases that rob you of
your intellectual capacity that are
extremely common,
that as many as 10% of people in these
poor neighborhoods have almost no
discussion. It was all just insults
and, and you know, you fucking chill and
this and that. You know, it's
going to be interesting, but no,
they're going to be a disaster. I
know, I know. Well, let me, let me,
I think that one of the
challenges for the platforms,
there's a lot of things start
out like learned to code.
I remember I watched that play out. Um,
Covington Catholic was another thing that,
I mean, God, um, I learned to code.
There was some of the people who are
trolling and just saying learn to code and
you know, whatever, you don't
have a right to not be offended.
But then there was the,
um,
the other accounts that kind of took it
that step further and began to throw in
like the ovens and the other stuff like
that. It would learn to code. Right.
And that's one of the
challenges with the platform,
which is if you're trying to assess the,
um, just the content itself, like
if you start doing keyword bands,
you're going to catch a lot of
shit that you don't want to catch.
But the flip side is if
you, you know, the, the,
this is the challenge of
moderating at scale, which
is, um, where, you know, what,
what side do you come down on,
do come down on saying like 75% of people
with Hashtag learn to code or just,
you know, I'm not doing
anything incredibly offensive.
And then the 25% who are,
they really changed the tone of the
overall campaign and the Hashtag for the
entire community.
And that's where you see Twitter I think
come in with the more heavy handed and
just shut it down kind
of thing. Um, I don't,
I don't know that there's an easy
answer. I think that we are, you know,
even today, what was the latest
kerfuffle? Elizabeth Warren got a,
an ad taken down on Facebook and then
there was a whole conversation about,
was Facebook censoring Elizabeth Warren.
I,
I personally didn't think that it
read like censorship, but it was, um,
it was an ad about, funny enough
her a platform to break up Facebook
is kind of, it seemed like it sort
of read more like a cell phone.
Like she had a picture of
Facebook's logo in the, um,
in the image and there that
violates the ads terms of service.
And the reason behind that is actually
because Facebook doesn't want people
putting up ads that have the Facebook
logo in it because that's how you scam
people or if it's a great way to,
to rip people often.
So probably just like an
automated, um, you know,
an automated take down like an automated,
they get halts the ad you have to go
and make some changes and then you can
proceed it back out again. Uh, but it
just happens at a time when there's like,
so little assumption of good faith
and so little assumption of, um,
such extreme, uh, anger
and polarization and, um,
you know, assumption that, um,
the platforms are censoring with,
with every little kind of moderation
snafu that it, it makes it,
I think,
I don't know how we have the conversation
in a way that's healthy and look
towards solutions as opposed to the left
screaming that it sends her the right
screaming that it's censored.
The platforms, um, you know,
trying to get around,
how do we both moderate and not moderate,
which is a tough position
to be in. Um, I think,
I don't have any
good,
no one does.
No could answer the issue
in Vigia discussed that
pretty much in depth what she
was saying.
This is about moderating and scale
when you're talking about millions and
millions and millions of posts and a
couple thousand people working for the
organization. And then
algorithms and computer learning
that's trying to keep up.
And that's where things like learned
to code and people are so outraged and
pissed off because when they
do get banned, they feel
like they've been targeted.
Whether you really just ran into some
code and then it's really hard to get
someone to pay attention to your appeal.
Right.
Because there's not enough people that
are looking at these appeals and there's
probably millions of appeals every day.
It's almost impossible.
Yeah. And there's, you know,
you'd depending on which,
um, which side you're on,
you're also here like,
um,
this person is harassing me and I'm
demanding moderation and nobody's doing
anything about it. Uh, so
it's, it's definitely I think,
gotten worse. Um, it's,
it's interesting to look back at
2016 and wonder how much of the,
um,
where we are now is in part because not
a whole lot happened in 2016 in 2016 it
was 2015 in particular, very
light, like almost no moderation,
just kind of let it all hang
out there and I look at it, um,
I look at it now,
particularly as it evolved into
this conversation about free speech,
public squares,
um,
and what the new kind of infrastructure
for speech and what rights we should
expect on it.
It's a really tough,
um, you know, I think some of it is,
is almost like the people who are,
who hear the words free speech and they
just assume that it's people asking for
carp launch, right. To harass
and saying, you know, um,
how do we balance that?
You have to think Jack and vagina
were saying this on your show. 'Em,
how do we maximize the number of people
who are involved in making sure that all
voices do get heard without
being unnecessarily heavy
handed and moderating a
thought or content and instead
moderate behavior and um,
and said moderate,
um,
particular types of signatures of things
that are inauthentic or things that are
coordinated and looking at this again
gets to disinflation too rather than
trying to police disinformation
by looking at content,
really looking instead at actions and
behavior and account authenticity and
dissemination patterns cause a lot of
the worst trolls and stuff or just using
these throw away accounts
and then they disappear. Well
you have the impression myself that when
we're talking about censorship we're
talking about moderating content that
really we're talking about this current
era and that what's
coming is essentially a,
we're like putting up a small like twig
fence and a herd of stampeding buffaloes
on the way in terms of the,
the more invasive or the more,
the more potent levels of
technology that are on the way.
I just feel like I feel like we're,
everything is moving into very specific
direction and that very specific
direction is less boundaries between
people and information and that includes
communication and it's going
to be insanely impossible,
insanely difficult or nearly
impossible to to moderate in 10 years.
I just don't think,
I don't think that's going to be,
I don't think it's going to be in the
wheelhouse. I just, I think it's going to,
we're,
we're entering into some weird place
where we either going to have to stay off
of social media because it's just too
toxic or grow a thick skin and just be
able to deal with anything.
And then if that's the case,
how are we going to be able to
differentiate between things that are
particularly designed to,
to manipulate a specifically designed
to manipulate us and change our opinions
by foreign entities like this.
You know, this Russian troll farm.
I do think the, the, you
know, when I think about like,
so if we believe that the misinformation
is impart facilitated by gainable
algorithms,
consolidation and then the targeting,
the kind of things we've talked
about through this conversation,
then I think that the algorithms piece,
the manipulatable algorithms,
that's really squarely the
responsibility of the platforms.
I don't think that there's any
regulation or, um, you know,
any kind of framework that's going to
come from Congress that's going to address
that. Well, that was pretty clear from
the Facebook hearings, right? I mean,
they barely understand that don't
know an android phone, an iPhone.
They really don't know what's
going on. Tim Apple. Yeah. Yeah.
That's the king of the world.
Right?
So as he did that on purpose,
which is even more hilarious,
just say you fucked up, man. I mean
to say that you've nuked Tim Cook,
his real name wasn't Tim Apple two.
It is funny. Call them to apple.
Although I did.
I appreciate it.
The rest of like every CEO in silicon
valley changing their Twitter handle
afterwards. Yeah. That was fun.
But I think the, uh, which,
and I just lost my train of
thought on that too. Sorry.
We're talking about you were, you
were talking about them. Oh yeah.
Regulate any algorithm.
Yeah.
So I think that ultimately the algorithmic
piece does remain squarely in the
purview of the platforms. And that's
because it's an arms race, right?
As they change their algorithm a little
bit, tweak it for the product function,
which they just do in
their roles business. Um,
there is no that's going to come
down fast enough to catch that.
I think actually finance is an interesting
parallel here cause like in the
financial markets there kinase multi
tiered levels of regulation and oversight
so that there's always
some entity responsible,
whether it's the exchange or a self
regulatory organization or the government.
And the SEC looking to see
if like information integrity
in the markets is being
maintained. Right. There's no shitty
algorithm coming in to manipulate people.
It's just making sure that
we have that level of trust.
So I think that right now the tech
ecosystem is lacking regulation and all of
its forms.
So that will likely change.
But the argument for decentralization is,
I don't know how you execute it.
I the antitrust thing in particular as
it as it comes up so much more now, um,
just me,
I don't know under what economic grounds
you make that claim that's way outside
of my wheelhouse and my area.
But there is something to
be said for this, you know,
return to decentralization in some way.
Yeah,
I like it lets people have what
they want. Um, and it lets you,
you know, read, it's a great
example. You have these, um,
it's almost like federalism.
You have this central platform,
but then you have these little communities
under it and each community has its
own norms.
Each community has its own rules.
Nobody who violates the moderator rules
in a reddit and scream censorship has
really taken seriously, right. The,
this is the rules of the community
or in the community. There you go.
And this was how in the olden days of
the Internet, like use nets and things,
you would have this as the community
that you've chosen to be a part of.
If you don't like the
moderation standards, you'd
go to this other community.
Right.
I think the concern with consolidation
is that people who do get moderated away
feel like there's nowhere for them to go,
um,
that they've lost access
to the entire world. Um,
so I think if you have that
decentralization that it in some ways,
um, it, it,
it stops being quite so much
of a freedom of speech issue.
If you can't speak on,
you know, if, if you,
if everything is like if there's 50
different platforms and you fall foul of
some sort of norms or standards or
community membership in this one,
you can go over here to this other one.
Right.
And then the idea that somebody has
moderated you away or a d platform,
do you or something is
much less, um, potent.
Maybe if there are alternatives
though, if you dock someone or
something along those lines. Yeah,
there's still like federalism thing.
It's like
moderation at the lower levels
versus, um, it's kind of top level.
Like you're summarily booted off.
Yeah. That seems like the
best approach. Right? Like,
it seems like the best approach is to
sort of let these communities sort of
establish themselves.
But even inside those communities,
then you have people that gained power
through moderation and they sorta abusing
it and then it becomes some sort
of a weird hierarchy. It's like
the decentralization in general.
It's probably the right
move for all this stuff.
But how does that happen with something
like Facebook or Twitter without
government intervention?
And I, you know, this,
one of the things that Tim
Paul was bringing up, like
if you guys don't do this,
if you don't handle this,
it's entirely possible somewhere down
the line you're going to be regulated by
the government.
Do you really want that?
But that's an inevitability whether they
think so. Yeah. At this point, yeah,
it's going to happen.
Well,
you know,
honestly I say that and I think back to
the reality which is in this congress
with this executive, I don't know how
we get any regulation through. Um,
I,
I think we've seen some examples
like the honest ads act,
which was introduced right
before the first tech hearing,
if I'm remembering the timeline correctly.
So that would have been like late 2017.
And what they said was,
um,
it's when you can no longer have like
a free for all with ads on social
platforms where nobody knows who paid
for it or where it's coming from or
anything like that. And um,
and what they, you know,
that,
so senator Klobuchar and Senator Warner
and I think Senator Mccain also was, uh,
was part of this,
um,
create this law saying that the platforms
have to follow the rules that TV and
radio already follow.
And this is an example of
recognizing the role that, that,
you know, these are no longer
startups. They can't be, you know,
that that can't meet these obligations.
It used to be that Facebook was
exempt from these, um, from these, uh,
disclosure requirements because
they're ads used should be those,
remember those tiny postage stamp sized
things that were on the right side of
the page. So they had a finding.
It was, they were, they were,
um,
given the same exemption that campaign's
kept for like skywriting and postage
and pencils,
you know,
where it's like literally the form factor
of the content makes it such that you
can't put the ad disclaimer on there.
And it used to be that
all of the advertising on
Facebook was regulated using
that same finding that,
that,
that these postage stamp size
things are too small to put the,
the disclosures on.
And then of course,
as we know that evolved into the ads
being looking much like an organic post.
And so now they do have these
little little things that
pop up where you can see
why you got targeted and what it is.
I think that that's an example of like
the credible threat of regulation and the
public opinion moving the platform to
take an action that it wouldn't have
necessarily done on its own. So
it's not regulation, but it's, um,
it's a nudge through public opinion and,
um,
the credible threat of future regulation.
We've seen California go after
the platforms. Also recently,
there was a California GDPR
thing from last year, um,
California legislature saying we're
going to pass a privacy requirement. Um,
and uh, and they did it. They got it
done. What is the privacy requirement?
Oh boy.
Um,
I feel like I'm probably not the best
person to explain this because I don't
know the specifics, but the GDPR was
the law in the UK and in Europe. Um,
that protects the data. It creates
particular protections like you're,
um,
you have to re opt in for targeting there
certain kinds of targeting that they
can't do, certain types of data
that you can request they delete.
So this is a provision that took effect
in Europe last year and we don't have
that same law here in the u s where we
don't have the same data protections as
the Europeans.
And so California Gdpr was the
California state government,
the state Senate legislature passing a
law that basically mimicked a lot of the
provisions of what the
Europeans were given under Gdpr.
But what that did was it created a law
that applied to the people of California.
And so Facebook and Twitter and the
others don't want to be in a position of
having to have this, um, you know,
kind of balkanization or a bomb,
a legal requirements.
And so they in turn have now I believe,
gone to Congress suggesting that a,
that we're going to need to have a federal
solution that applies to all of the u
s so a federal level privacy regulation,
um,
because they don't want to have to
adhere to the privacy regulations of like
each individual us state.
One solution that's been tossed up was
that people would have to somehow or
another confirm their identity.
Then instead of it being an anonymous
posts that it would have to say,
Rene de Resta, like, I know who you
are. You have to have a photograph,
have some sort of a government
id shows that it's you,
that we would somehow or
another minimize trolling,
minimize this information if you,
if your account was connected to a social
security number or whatever it was.
The problem, of course is that these
damn things get hacked all the time.
And if your Twitter account gets hacked,
now they have your social security number,
they have your address,
they have your information that
you use to sign up. And you know,
there's a lot of it unless there's
some way and there isn't too,
absolutely lock down all that data and
make sure that it's an accessible to some
sort of third party that doesn't seem
like a likely course of action either.
And I think, um, the question of identity,
I think most social science research,
um,
that I've read has suggested that that's
not necessarily the be all and end all.
I think it depends on, um, [inaudible]
per your point what you're trying to do.
I'm thinking right now of the,
um,
there was this request for FTC comments
for net neutrality and I know that,
um, a lot of them were, you know,
whoever left them there, lot tons,
I think millions actually of,
of these fake comments that were
left on the net neutrality, um,
call for public comment
where they were scraping, um,
like the, you know, those, um,
those crappy data brokers as horrible
things where like your name and your
address is up there and like, no matter
how hard you try, you can't get it done.
Um,
so scraping those to grab names and
addresses and then email addresses and
leaving. I'm leaving comments
pretending to be those people. It's,
it's hard.
Nobody,
most people don't want to enter their
social security number and to some form or
validation. Um, a lot of people
will point to things like, well,
you know, America has a strong
commitment to anonymous speech. So,
um, so there's that and cultural
thing. Oh, I think, you know,
people will point to like a federalist
papers and penis and so on and so forth.
Official blowers and whistleblowers.
Yeah, I think I've seen, uh,
I remember when Facebook did make it a
requirement to you have to validate your
actual name and address.
They send a postcard to your house
if you want to run political ads. Um,
and then I remember people complaining
that people who didn't have you know,
that this was going to,
um, what was it? Oh God,
this was during the Daca
arguments. So, um, that, yeah,
during the, it was during some of the
illegal immigration debates, right? Right.
As this was happening,
um,
people began complaining that immigration
activists who are undocumented would
not be able to run Facebook ads because
they didn't have a identification to
verify with.
So no matter what people put out,
there's going to be somebody
who has a complaint about it.
So we're in this, this
like, um, this gridlock,
everybody recognizes that the situation
sucks and that social media is a
disaster on a myriad number of,
of fronts.
And there's not much in the way of
a plausible solutions I think for
disinflation in particular,
just to stay in my wheelhouse,
we're trying to push towards
multistakeholder ism,
which is just to say can we create,
um,
the back channel channels of communication
that have come up for election
integrity and things over the last
few years, last year and a half.
Can we standardize that in some way?
Um, can we create an oversight body?
Maybe the FTC that is at
least responsible for, um,
having some oversight to make sure the
platforms are doing enough. But this is,
I think this is going to be
the, the theme of 2019. Does it,
does it go the antitrust route?
Does it go the privacy route?
Like does it do a kind of
hybrid combination of multiple,
um,
tackling multiple problems at once.
It really curious to see how we shake
this out cause it just seems like no even
agreeing on what the problem is or
not quite there yet. And you're,
you are seeing calls like
particularly from Elizabeth Warren for
breaking up a lot of these
larger institutions, not just,
not just even social media,
but even Amazon.
She's talking about breaking up a
lot of these bigger companies. Um,
it's the problem with that is like to
what and make them what and then what
happens. And then, you know, one of the,
what if one of those things that you
broke up that becomes Twitter becomes more
popular than the other Twitter and it
has much more attendance than what he'd
do.
Yeah. You should get one of those
people onto it to just talk about that.
Cause um, Lena Connor or somebody who, um,
really Matt Stoller knows this space
in and out and I just don't, um,
the eye, you know,
personally what I feel like the,
a lot of people are moving
into smaller communities.
A lot of people are moving into
groups are moving into whatsapp chats.
They're recognizing that the system as
it is right now has this toxicity and are
withdrawing a bit. I don't know if
you've seen this in your friends,
your community,
but yeah.
Well I have it in,
Jamie and I were actually talking
about it yesterday in terms of the,
the use of Twitter, the use
of Twitter dropped. And um,
one thing that I notice is that my
follower numbers doesn't move very much on
Twitter as opposed to like Instagram. I
don't really use Facebook, but Instagram,
there's a giant difference in how
many followers I get per day on either
platform. And it seems to me that
the people that are using Twitter,
they have kind of like locked in.
They've found their little
communities and it's mostly toxic.
I mean, I mean, I'm sure I'm
generalizing, I'm not, it's,
I am for sure. It's probably not even
10% toxic, but it seems toxic. You know,
when you look at those kind of
comments and anytime something happens,
it seems like the reaction to it is very
rarely is it some sort of a objective,
rational discourse.
It's most likely just insults and
swears. It's weird. It's just, uh, it, it,
people are communicating in a way online
that they communicated in real life.
There would be blood in the streets.
I think about that a lot actually.
Yeah, I do. I think that the um,
and what are the, you know, especially I
was listening to your, to your thing with,
with Tim and Andy and Jack and vagina,
the
yeah. Of the Public Square.
And I use this metaphor too,
like when I write about them that
the privatized public square,
but then I think about it sometimes I'm
like we've never had a national public
square.
There is no such thing in the history
of America as a National Public Square.
There are regional public squares
or a town squares, state squares,
you know where there is again
this kind of federalism, um,
people who have self selected to live
in a particular community norms in that
community.
But if I were to go up to you in a
public square and start screaming in your
face or you know,
being an asshole and trying to get a
whole mob together to go after you,
like probably somebody would intervene
either a bystander or the police.
And we have notions of like
nuisance and things like that.
We have notions of like there's,
there's more of a,
an intuitive sense of the
balance between speech,
which is to be protected and then the
kind of fighting words and that sort of
thing. There's no clear lines on that.
There's not much in the way of norms.
And when you're online there is nobody
who is going to come in and step in and
intervene in a way that would play out in,
in real life.
So the, I think that we, we have,
we just haven't quite ported those
norms of basic good behavior in the real
world,
um,
into this massive roiling crowd that's
just sort of always on at all times.
And that's, that's sort of more
where we are on social media.
Well,
I think there's actually a carry over
to real life from social media that you
can find in these protests at universities
when conservative speakers come and
then antifa wants to shut them down.
And then you have people like
the proud boys fight with Antifa.
I don't remember that before ever.
I think this is,
this is a byproduct of the
type of communication that's
the norm on social media.
I really think that's
what's happening here.
I really think that instead of
social media mimicking real life,
real life is starting to mimic the kinds
of interactions that people have on
social media and with
violent repercussions. It's
certainly if not violent,
very aggressive and angry in a way
that it go back before social media.
When was the law,
I mean in 2000 and in the 1990s how often
were there these incredibly volatile
protests at universities where you have
conservatives and liberals screaming at
each other and you have these,
these people that are being
deployed at formed and,
and they won't let them speak at
these colleges and then they're,
they're gathering up this online mob to
try to bolster support and then people
come to meet them. We're going to stop
them at all costs. And it's kind of,
it's kind of flavoring real life versus
real life being represented in social
media. Yeah, I don't, I don't remember
it from when I was in college either. No,
it didn't exist. Not, not the expert on,
you got to go back college
protests and the, you know,
maybe people would point to the
60s want to go back to Kent State.
That's what I was gonna say.
You gotta go back to war protest.
But they were protesting
something very specific,
an unjust war that nobody wanted to
be a part of. This is a weird time.
Yeah, it is. It, um,
I know it feels unstable.
Yes, yes. That's the best way.
But it's also awesome. I'm enjoying
the shit out of it. I mean it's,
well, because I, I love fact that it, it,
for the first time in my life,
it does not seem like the government
has a fucking handle on how people are
behaving and thinking at all.
Like they don't know what's going on.
It's like you've got people that are,
you know,
people that are trying out
socialists tropes and, and,
and socialist ideas for the first time
in the main stream and they're getting a
big groundswell of support behind it.
And then you have a lot of people that
are like pro nationalists and Pro America
for the first time. In a long time.
And that's getting a lot of support.
There's more discourse now,
even if it's toxic.
And I think a lot of it isn't, I
think, like I said, if 10% is toxic,
it seems like it's all toxic. One out
of 10 people calls you a piece of shit.
You're like, I've got to get out of this
fucking forum. Right. I mean, that's,
that's really how it feels.
I think that's true. There's definitely
a, um, I've noticed that too.
The actual numbers of,
of,
of a horrible trolls or maybe this
afternoon will be different. I don't know,
don't try to prove you
wrong. It's, I, you know,
I'm on Twitter a lot and, uh, it's the
platform I use more than any other. Um,
so for all the, you know,
for all the complaints,
I do feel like there's some real
value there for me personally.
And, um, and I, I like,
I like the serendipity of,
of the unexpected being pushed into
my feed occasionally. Sometimes it's,
you know, uh, sometimes of
course I get angry or, you know,
feel annoyed or think, why the hell
didn't you know, why, why this? Um,
but I think ultimately the,
there is a lot of value to the platform.
I think we're,
unfortunately,
I really do believe that so much of the
polarization and the conversation around
speech is people who got burned
during the laissez faire days of 2015,
2016 in mentally linking up the idea
of free speech with the idea of being
harassed online. And I
think when you look at, um,
this is purely an opinion, I have
absolutely no data to bear this out.
But when you look at those
Pew studies that show, um,
that younger people are
more likely to want,
you know, it's safe spaces or less,
you know, less offensive opinions. I,
I do sometimes wonder if that's a,
um,
an effect of coming of age
at a point when, you know,
random ass holes were screaming at you on
social platforms 24, seven versus like,
I didn't have that experience growing up.
I didn't have that experience until
I was like 25, you know, so, um,
so maybe there is something
pre your point about that. Um,
the almost there is not much
of a difference as you know,
people spend so much time online.
This is where you're having your social
engagements is where you're having your
conversation. So it does shape
the way people think about,
you know,
their experience of,
of what it means to have a conversation
and what it means to speak freely.
I think that's one of the interesting,
uh, you know, it doesn't help that the um,
but free speech has sometimes in many
cases become a Figley for I want carte
blanche to, you know, say all kinds
of mean shit to people all day long.
No consequences.
Yeah.
They think they should be able to do that
cause that that falls into the blanket
of freestyle.
Um,
there's also an issue I think with
young kids today that have smartphone
addictions. People today I should say,
I forgot young kids. How about me?
Humans with smartphone addiction and when
you're online and when you think about
the majority of your
interactions with human beings,
but there's a lot of folks that are
on their phone eight hours in a day.
That's probably me.
But think about those interactions.
That's a shocking number of interactions
with people that you're not even direct
physical, the presence of your,
you're, you're not looking
at them. You're not, you,
you're not waiting for them to talk.
You're not considering what they're
saying in our reading, social cues,
all the things that make us human,
those are all thrown out the window.
You're just looking at text and
it might be coming from Russia,
the texts that you're getting upset at
in responding to mean per year research.
Really there's a direct possibility.
It's not even a fucking
person or a person, but not,
not really representing
their actual thoughts. Just
trying to push your buttons.
Yeah, no, that's true. It's a, it's
not even Russian trolls. It's just the,
um, the amount of, I think it really is,
we're in the unique time work.
It's hard to know who
you're engaging with.
It's hard to gauge whether it's
good faith. It's, I mean, I,
I react sometimes where
I'll see a response and go
click into the person's feed
to try to decide if I should take this
as a seriously good faith inquiry or if
it's like a, like a, you
know, kind of vaguely cloaked.
Fuck you, you know? Right,
right. You don't have to do
that when you're in person.
It's a very different and
very different experience.
Yeah. I have a friend of
mine who's a, a young,
single male and he was going
through his direct messages and uh,
these girls were sending him all these
naked photos and videos and uh, he's like,
look at this man. I go, let
me see your phone. And I said,
let me click on that link. I go, she
has one picture on her page. Right.
You fucking dummy. This is
probably not even a person. Like,
who knows what this is.
Someone from Nigeria is trying to get
your credit card information. Yeah.
Cat Fishing. Yup. Yeah. I mean, they're
trying to get you and he's like, oh yeah.
Like, wow. How do you did not go to
her page? Cause I had just, you know,
I thought it was a girl send
me naked pictures. Just, yeah,
they just do that sometimes.
Well they definitely do do that sometimes,
but I mean, people are weird. They do
all kinds of weird things. But you know,
there's,
there's a lot of these fake accounts and
I don't know what they're trying to do.
They're trying to get money from people or
that does come up. I've seen
'em every now and then, uh,
if you follow reporters on Twitter,
particularly ones who have like open dms,
I'll periodically post the
insane catfishing, you know,
stuff that they get where it's like
all about money or I don't have,
I don't know. I, God bless people who have
opened dams. I don't know how they do. It
makes me glad I'm not a
journalist. Yeah. So overall,
are you happy that you got into all this?
Does this,
does this change your
perceptions on communication?
I feel like there's,
I have tried over the years,
whether it's conspiracy theorists,
communities are terrorists or, um,
or, uh, you know, Russia, Iran
state. The state sponsored actors,
the domestic ideologues. Um, I
have tried to always say like,
here's the specific kind of forensic
analysis of this particular operation and
then here is what we can maybe take
from it and make, make changes.
Um, we've, we've seen some
of that begin to take shape.
And so I feel grateful to
have had the opportunity to work towards
connecting those dots and work towards
having this conversation.
I'm meaning meaning helping
people understand what's going on.
I think I am not,
I am most concerned about the,
as this gets increasingly easy to
do through things like chatbots.
Um, you know, now there's these, um,
you've seen the, uh, the website,
this person does not exist.com.
So it's a,
there's a technology called
a machine learning technique,
generative adversarial
networks. And they, um,
it's these basically there in this
particular application working to create
pictures of people, faces of people. And
so this website is, when you go to it,
it pulls up a, yeah, there you go. So
this person does not actually exist.
It's not a religion. Yeah.
And so these are all, um,
these are computer generated. Yup. So,
and you can see created by against,
it says it down at the bottom there.
So these are not real people.
And so we have increasingly
sophisticated chat technology.
We have increasingly sophisticated,
like you're not going to detect
that image somewhere else.
That old trick of like right click and
look and see if you're talking to someone
with a stock photo that goes right out
the window is stuff like this gets easier
and easier to do. Deep faking the
deep fakes on the video front.
I think that it does change.
I think we haven't quite adapted to what
is it like to live in a world where so
much of the Internet is fake.
And I do think per your point
about identity that there
will be groups of people
that self select into
communities where identity is
um, mandatory. You know, we're,
we're,
this is who you are and you have some
sort of verification versus people who
choose to live in the world of,
um, you know, drink from the fire,
take it all in and try to
filter it out yourself. Um,
so we look at these evolving
technologies and I don't necessarily feel
particularly optimistic in the short term.
I think that ultimately it does,
like we change as a society to a
large extent. And in response to this,
we think about, um, you know,
they're going to be some fixes that the
platforms are gonna be able to undertake.
They're going to be, we're going to get
better at detecting the stuff. Maybe,
you know,
the adversary will evolve.
Hopefully we get better at
detecting it as it evolves.
But it's,
I think we fundamentally
ultimately change.
Like people become more aware that this
is a thing. They are more skeptical, uh,
that does change are there are ways of
interacting with each other. Uh, but I,
I feel like that is going to be
the direction that this goes.
There's the more like,
you know,
the thing that keeps me up at
night would be more the, um,
the ease of,
of turning this from a social
media problem until like
a real world war problem.
Meaning, um, as an example,
back in 2014 when the first thing
is internet research agency dead,
September 11th, 2014,
they created a hoax, um,
saying that isis had attacked a chemical
plant down in Louisiana and it's called
the Columbia, the Columbia
Chemical Pr. Um, plant hoax is,
I think there's a Wikipedia
article about it now.
But what happened was they
created a collection of websites.
They created fake CNN mockups,
Twitter accounts,
text messages that went to local people,
radio station, Collins, you name it,
everything to create the impression that
a chemical factory had just exploded in
Louisiana.
And there was some attribution to isis.
And this was done on September 11th.
So this is the kind of thing
where this actually did go viral.
Like I remember this happening,
not as a social media researcher.
I just remember it actually being
pushed into my social media feed.
So you have these,
um,
and we didn't know that it
was the Internet research
agency for year and a half
after.
But this is the kind of thing where you
look at parts of the world that aren't
the u s like the recent, um,
drama between India and Pakistan.
And you can see how these kinds
of things can go horribly,
horribly wrong if the wrong person is
convinced that something has happened or
if there's a,
you know,
or if this leads to our riot or if
this leads to real world action.
I think that's, um, one of the main fears.
As this gets better and better,
the video fakes get better,
the people fakes get better. What,
you know, what do you do then?
So,
yeah, what do you do when you see those
images, those images, fake images.
Those are stunning. They're so good. I
mean, it just makes you wonder, I mean,
and we're going to get to a point where
if someone's not in front of you talking,
you're going to look at a video. You're
not going to have any idea. You know,
they're doing those deep fakes when were
famous faces and they put them in porn
films and it's, it's stunningly
good. I mean, it's a, it's amazing.
And they're there.
They're also with someone like me,
I'm fucking doomed because there's
thousands of hours of me talking.
I've said everything. Yeah. So
you could take this new, uh,
there's this new product programs that
are editing audio and you could splice
together audio and video. Now did I even
splice it? The computer will generate,
yeah, just, it's insane. It generates
your lip movements, everything. I mean,
it's really stunning.
It's really stunning.
And it's only gonna get
crazier and crazier and it's
going to be very difficult
to, unless something is actually
happening right in front of your face,
it's going to be very difficult
to be able to differentiate.
And then I'm more worried about augmented
reality and virtual reality and this
stuff making its way into it.
And when we're going to dive w w willingly
with a big smile on her face into the
majors.
Have you watched that
recently? No, I haven't.
I watched that on a plane like
a month ago or something. No,
it holds up really well. Top, like
it's, it's insane except for the, um,
except for the phone boots and so on.
One thing where like there's no fun
was anymore, but everything else is um,
wow. Yeah. It's, it's, I don't know
you as you've seen it recently.
I just bought it on four k cause like
I forgot and 99 there wasn't barely HD
back then and I just wanted to see what
it was like rewashed it forgot how good
it was. And two, two and a half
hours flew by the whole movie.
Yeah.
It's,
it's amazing how that seemed preposterous
in 99 or whatever it was like,
oh, this is just psi Phi
and now you're like, hey,
this is a little closer.
Like the idea of have you messed around
at all with like HTC vive or Oculus?
I, I tried, I was a VC briefly
like back in, back in, um,
five, six years ago now. And I tried
one from, um, I think it's USC, right?
Those southern California has a
bunch of really good labs down here.
And I tried one where it was like a
Zombie holodeck simulator and it was, um,
it wasn't just the Vr, it was also, it was
immersive. So they had a backpack on me.
Um, and it was, it was
actually scary as hell. Yeah.
I was like, this is really good. This
is, I like, I love first person shooters.
I think there's so much fun, but this
was just the first time or in the,
in the game you have like a
bat or something and you're
your lecture of beats on
piece together with the band and they're
like all up in your face. And um,
I don't know if that thing ever came
to market, but Dan was a good too. Well
they have a company called,
it's called the void now and they have
this a wreck it Ralph one and I did it
with my kids recently and you put on a
haptic feedback vest and you go through
this environment and it's crazy.
I mean you're,
it's very clear that you're in a
video game. It doesn't seem real,
but it is so much better than anything
that existed five years ago. And you go,
okay, well what is with the exponential
increase in power of technology,
what does this going to be like 10 years?
What's it going to be like in
15 it's going to be impossible.
Differentiate cause now it's a vest.
It's just a vest and not strapped
into a chair. He can move around.
So you're going through this whole
warehouse that they have set up for these
games and even picking up physical objects
and they look different in your hands
than they do when you,
when you look at them without the headgear
on centers for that, they have them.
I haven't been to, they have one
outside of Disneyland. It's in Disney,
downtown Disney. It's called the
void. And then you go into these,
this one star wars one is a wreck it
Ralph one now they have them in malls,
small ones.
You sit in these little eggs and you go
on rollercoaster rides and you fight off
zombies and go into a haunted house.
It's getting weird and it's just
that we're, we're, you know,
I was a kid when video games were
these ridiculous Atari things.
We stuck cartridges in and you're
playing pong and now we're looking at
something that you're looking at these
images of people you see pores you see
there, you see the, the glistening of
their lips, you see their eyes. It's,
it's very strange.
It's very strange to think that those
are not really people and that we are
probably going to look at the,
all you have to do is create something
that is so large and the propaganda,
the so terrifying that it causes
you to act without double checking,
triple checking and making sure you
verify the fact that something has really
happened and then it sets into motion
some physical act in the real world that
you can't pull back. Like, and this
is does not related necessarily,
but what happened with Hawaii when they
got that false warning that nuclear
missiles were headed their way,
he imagined it was crazy and it was
just someone hit the wrong button.
I mean if we come to some sort of a point
in time where someone does something
like that on purpose and shows you video
that you really think New York City
just got nuked and you know,
you have to head to the hills and there's
a giant traffic jam on the highway and
people start shooting
each other. I mean, if,
if Russia really wants to fuck with us
what they're doing now with just this,
you know,
this IRA agency and all of these different
trolls that they've got set up to
sort of trying to get people to get
being conflict with each other. This is,
this is with primitive
crude text and memes.
What could be done in the future.
It's terrifying,
but live in a weird world.
Yeah, we're in agreement.
Yup. Let's end it there. All right.
Thank you so much. Really appreciate it.
Thanks for coming down.
It was,
and thank you for all your work and
exposing all this stuff. It's really,
really interesting and terrifying.
Uh,
tell people how they can get ahold of
you so they control you on Twitter.
My handle is at no upside,
no upside.
And you don't necessarily have an
Instagram. It's more like family.
My instruments, my kids. Yeah. All right.
Thank you Renee. Really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Bye everybody.